[Applause]
what do you think the most
difficult thing is for the average
person uh most people complain about
names and faces because it's something
that they they okay let's do names how
do we lock in names
yeah i mean it's just first of all
knowing how important it is
is really important you mentioned mom
and so uh mom another acronym and we'll
get back to fast also
uh we're closing on fast exactly but the
m
um so let's say uh anyone watching or
listening to this if they have trouble
remembering names which is 95
of the population right um but let's say
that
there was a suitcase of like a million
dollars cash for anybody who remembers
the name of the next stranger
who's who's joining us who's going to
remember that name yeah everybody right
yeah
and so the m in mom the first stem is
motivation
right and so i would say we're all great
learners when we're motivated
to learn right if we're motivated and
there's some kind of reward that comes
from it but i would just
say that maybe connecting with the
reason why
studying something that but that's why
we forgot a lot of things in school like
what are we using
the periodic table and the quadratic eq
what are we using that for yeah
so we probably don't remember it right
right but if you ask yourself simple
technique
a brain hack when you're meeting
somebody ask yourself why do i remember
this person's name
maybe it's to show the person some
respect maybe make a new friend maybe
get a referral maybe it's to practice
these things i learned on this podcast
you know because if you can't come up
with a reason you won't get the result
so it's so important when you read and
study if you're in school if you're
preparing for
something for work to tap into the
purpose because without that motivation
you're probably not going to remember
the owen mom was very simple we did this
kind of fun exercise where you shake out
your hand make a fist you know i told
people to put it to their chin
and everyone put it their cheek because
i did it to my cheek yeah you know the o
stands for observation and a lot of
times people blame their retention
and it's not your retention it's your
attention
you know because a lot of people they're
not really listening what are they doing
they're waiting for their turn to speak
yeah they're thinking about how they're
gonna respond yeah yeah you know and if
they're talking to themselves and
listening they're not gonna listen to
the other person so they're without
forgetting their name they're just not
hearing the name
so even if you take a word like listen
you write it down
and you do this little mental you know
gymnastics in your mind and switch the
letters around it spells another word
perfectly
the word listen is when you scramble the
letters spells the word
silent and people could be so much
better at remembering things if they
were just quiet and silent yeah you know
but a lot of times they won't because
they're
they're that monkey mind yeah sometimes
they're just anxious you know they maybe
want to impress somebody
and they're not listening to what
they're saying and sometimes the most
impressive thing
to somebody is just paying attention to
them yeah i think that's
and then that's so interesting to me
because so many people are trying to
impress by being interesting yeah yeah
look how cool i am
yeah you're really cool and that person
goes i like being around people who
think i'm cool
exactly and maybe it's not about being
interesting it's about being interested
yeah you know to somebody right because
everybody wants to feel like they're
heard and seen and asked questions
because it's everyone's favorite topic
yeah and then finally you know
motivation observation the last m
is are the methods that we talk about
yeah like the b swab and some of the
other techniques about saying the name
repeating it visualizing the person's
name and
yeah yeah what was that like um putting
their name
oh what did you what was the example
yeah mary
and then yeah yeah like here's the thing
that i would imagine a lot of people are
joining us they're better with faces
than they are with names yeah
right you look at somebody saying i
remember your face but i forgot your
name yeah
you never go to someone say the opposite
you never go i remember your name
i remember your name but i forgot your
face right dave you look different
right exactly and so the reason why is
there's a proverb that goes what i hear
i forget
what i see i remember what i do i
understand what i hear i forget
heard the name forgot it yep when i see
the face i'm gonna recall
yeah and what i do going back to
practice you know practice makes
progress right practice doesn't even
make perfect makes progress yeah then
you really understand so i would say
that when you visualize since you tend
to remember what you see try seeing what
you want to remember
so a person's name is mike imagine you
meet a mike and they they just jump on
the table and start seeing karaoke on a
microphone
you know a split second it makes you
laugh you're probably gonna remember it
okay touches you emotionally his name
is alex media yeah that's an invented
name
that's it how are you gonna remember it
yeah so i would say that
take the name and transform it into a
picture so if i say the word alex
what do you think of the person that
comes to your mind right now weird alex
trebek
there there there you go that that's
amazing and so if you can imagine alex
right and you could see the jeopardy
board and everything else like that then
that that's a way of associating things
together
you meet someone named emma right and
you think of you know like oh i have a
relative
that that's like that or emma you know
like a famous
emma or something that sounds like it so
if a person's you know name is
i mentioned andrew you know for
something that sounds like if you're
playing pictionary
and you draw those ears like sounds like
you know when you have to think in
pictures
yeah yeah yeah you know and somebody
thinks about an android
they're not going to call you android
but have you ever forgot someone's name
and you start going through the alphabet
like does it start with an a does it
start with a b and you get really
nervous when you get to like
w because there's not a lot of letters
like after that
but sometimes e and you think of eric
right or you think of
d and you think of dove or something
like that it just reminds you so if you
come up with something that
sounds like like mary you know the
person's getting married all of a sudden
it's
carol singing christmas carols for me
david whenever i meet someone named
david i think of a slingshot right to
their nose
because david and goliath goliath right
and it's so silly but then
it takes a split second and i can't
forget it because when i leave that
party or whatever later on i was like
what did i do that what happened there
oh i shot him in the nose with a
slingshot you create like a cartoon
almost in your head of an
activity that's associated with the name
it's a fun you know what it does it
overcomes what i call the six second
syndrome
when somebody tells you their name or
you have six seconds to do something
with it otherwise
it's gone in the ether right you're
never going to get it back so when it
does it gets you to focus on the person
and it gets you to focus on the name
so even when it doesn't work it still
tends to work because it gets you to
concentrate and pay attention yeah
so if a person's name is uh mark imagine
you're putting like a little check mark
on their forehead
like you would never forget that and
then that's what i remember and once you
know the person's name is mark yeah or
alex or anything else like that then the
picture disappears i don't think of
jeopardy anymore
you know because it was a means to an
end yeah right and how do kids remember
names
yeah like do they make do you have your
name made fun of growing up or andrew
not really andrew andrew i don't know
yeah that's what they'll do they'll like
they had their songs about it and you
know the name like quick i got you know
like
nestle quick and all this stuff kind of
stuff but that's how kids remember
things so using your imagination is
definitely a plus
yeah you also said uh
i think it was with the names you were
you were saying that you can
what was it put it in a scenario yeah
yeah like if you um
i think when you meet people with
unusualness oh yeah asking them yeah
what the etymology is but just like yeah
why are you named that
like if you said my name's alex media
it'd be like yeah why are you named
yeah who are you exactly everyone i
think a lot of people are flattered when
you hear a name that you haven't heard
before but how did you word it because
the way i say it is antagonistic yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
why are you named that yeah so when
somebody tells you their name
like their name could be a i met a
rudiger the other day right i was like
you know what's the origin how do you
spell it you know where where
is it from just right because curiosity
that interest being interested in
something yeah yeah because remember
like
we've all heard this but like name is a
sweetest sound to a person's ears
like think about like one of the first
words you learn how to write and you
know maybe growing up praising you for
just
doing it like sloppy and everything else
you know and so a name is so
important and so taking that name asking
about
how you spell it or who you're named
after or something like that takes
interest
plus it just helps you to ingrain it
also also as well
and it's more than just names that
you're doing that with right yeah
having a curiosity over anything is
gonna help you motivation and curiosity
is gonna
somebody told me a story about um bill
clinton
uh not an x-rated one and uh they said
uh
he's he was like they were at a party
with bill clinton and they were at that
party and there was also some family
friends who are at that party
and all them left the party thinking
that bill clinton
found them to be the most interesting
human being yeah that has ever existed
like they all left the party with the
exact same feeling like that guy thought
i was the best ever
he's got great taste and then when they
reconvened afterwards they shared the
story
and they're like oh [ __ ] this is just
this guy's skill
he has this amazing ability and maybe
it's like what you're saying maybe he
wasn't entertaining maybe he was paying
attention
maybe he was interested yeah i i i
um i met him briefly years ago and like
two years later
i went to a charity event and it was two
thousand people in this gala for uh
you know this this good cause and i sit
at my table i was assigned to i was the
first one there
and uh when i sat down shortly
afterwards force whitaker
sits right next to me right and then
richard branson sits next to him
and i'm like whoa i think i got like
sitting at the wrong and then actually
ashton kutcher sits down yeah his twin
brother sits down
and bill clinton sits right next to me
yeah and i was just like wow and i and
i swear to you he remembered my name
really and we only talked for like a
couple
a few minutes before unbelievable and
and i was like okay he was fed that like
he knew who's sitting at his table
clearly
and then i swear to you he picks up the
conversation we had two years ago
no yeah and i and and i and i was like i
need to know how you do this you know
i'm the memory guy and he starts
talking to me about his grandfather in
arkansas how in the living room he would
tell stories to all the kids
but something different he would quiz
each of them individually to see if they
were
paying attention and while he was
explaining this to me
i was like i i've got this eerie feeling
because i felt like
i was the only one in that room of 2000
people you know
has have you ever met somebody that
they're just so fixated
and you feel like you're the only one
that exists and and i realized that his
incredible
memory and regardless of politics people
would say that he has got this charisma
great connector great communicator
he's got this powerful presence and i
think his incredible memory
and his powerful presence with people
comes from being powerfully present with
people
that his incredible memory and his
powerful presence
comes from being powerfully present
right and
you know when he's looking at you he's
like asking
you know thoughtful questions he's
clearly he's listening with the
idea that he wants to learn and uh and
you feel like you're the only one
and there's many more important people
in that room than me certainly at that
table than i was but i felt like i was
the only one
and so i thought i was the only one that
was special there
hate to break it down yeah but again
that's great that you asked him though
and he was forthcoming with information
he
very much so so his father would tell a
story
right and then or his grandfather yeah
would tell a story and then like during
the story
i would just quiz them to see if they
were paying attention to what was going
on
and i think that's an incredible art you
know i had to um
i got to i mentioned larry king and we
did each other's uh show
and uh and he has this curiosity he
always thinks he's like
the dumbest person in the room i love it
you know and he has no ego about it and
he's just like very real
and when he asks a question he's
sincerely you know yeah
he sincerely wants to know the answer
yeah you know and you know they say that
you know if you're the smartest one in
the room you're in the wrong room or
whatever
but he has this genuine caring sincerity
you know and so it just comes so
authentic i wonder if
um an excellent memory
increases self-confidence yeah
because think about it like if every
interaction you're having with a human
being you can recall that last
interaction
you'd be pretty confident in that
conversation you know something about
that person
you can always reference a past story
picking up where you left off
you're gonna baffle them i mean when
clinton started that story again
yeah you would have taken it back right
and i've seen some impressed things but
that just like
yeah because you know he meets a lot of
people yeah he does it for a living yeah
literally just meets people yeah that's
it i mean
whoa yeah when you when you meet i think
he's writing down these events you think
i i don't know about him but i just know
that there
that this is a trainable skill it's
available for all of us
when because how you can again show
somebody you already care for their
business their future their
if you don't care enough just remember
them when you can remember their their
fiance's name right or you can remember
important things about them
yeah they feel like like you care right
and i think
that that's such an important skill now
and like not just business etiquette and
networking i think it's an important
skill in
in life and every well we're all
forgetful right it happens to the best
of us
and yet we could be better and it's
worth it because even when it comes to
names and faces
unfortunately it's a standout skill
because if you could walk into a room
and meet 20 strangers
and leave saying goodbye to every single
one of them by name
who are they all gonna remember right
they're gonna remember you
people remember people who remember them
you